in 27
I was upon the personal insistence of
Alfred Adler expelled from the rose of
the adlerian society because I had
become too much unorthodox and there
upon I started slowly to develop my own
system that is global therapy in 1937
Frankel opened his private practice for
a neurology and psychiatry in Vienna but
was forced to close it after a short
time some months later Hitler's troops
marched into Austria
and things changed what were the
consequences of the Angelus in 1938 for
you personally
of course from one day to the next
everything changed both in the
professional as well as in personal and
familiar regards
I then was appointed the head of the
Department of Neurology at the Jewish
hospital the so-called Road Child
Hospital
but I could stay there
and keep my old parents from being
deported
until 1942 only and then the three of us
were deported to various concentration
camps my father died in tourism stud my
mother went directly from the railway
station of Auschwitz into a gas chamber
and myself
after entering Auschwitz
had a full-length book manuscript
in my pocket in the pocket of my
overcoat and everything was taken away
of course
but after Auschwitz I reconstructed the
manuscript and it became the book the
doctor and the Soul what my American
Publishers have sometimes stated on the
back cover of my books is not correct I
did not come out as they say from
Auschwitz with a brand new type of
psychotherapy but I had entered it
already with the respective manuscript